here's what would happen if you drilled
a hole through the Earth First you'd
need a really big drill it would take a
few years to complete this project but
once you're done travel from one side of
the planet to another would be
revolutionized with a gravity train
that's a train that would accelerate
using only the force of gravity and it
would protect you from the Searing heat
and extreme pressure your journey would
start in the Earth's crust and
eventually you'd reach the mantle this
would be the longest part of the trip
since it
84 percent of the Earth's volume at a
depth of about 3
3000 core and
5 000 kilometers below the surface you'd
reach the Earth's inner core this giant
solid iron sphere has a mind-boggling
temperature of 5200 degrees Celsius this
is just halfway through your journey and
now you'll have to do all that in
reverse order to pop out on the other
side of the planet so